today we will dive into 3d animation
with javascript using
3js and gsap
in this workshop i will teach you the
basics of 3gs and how to incorporate
gsap to add extra animations
and let me give you an overview of this
workshop today we will go through scenes
cameras lighting objects and material
and all of this will be rendered through
the browser
after this i will show you how to
incorporate more animations with gsap
and finally we will end the workshop by
teaching you how to
import 3d models into the browser so
what is 3gs 3js is a cross browser
javascript library and api it is used to
create and display animated 3d computer
graphics in a web browser using webgl
the source code can be accessed through
github node.js and cdn which is a
content delivery network or the source
files could be downloaded through their
website at 3js.org
so let's get started
[Music]
all right so let's begin um first we
will get
get done with the html and css so we'll
just make those files so the first file
we will need is index.html
then we will need style.css
and we will need our javascript
app.javascript now i do have a few extra
files and i'll explain what those are
later
but first let's go into the html file
use the boilerplate and
name the title 3d animations
and let us link the style sheet
by saying link and css
and then we need to link our javascript
we do that by
scri
pt and then we also give the source
which is app.js
now let's add a few extras a few styles
uh so we don't have to worry about that
later so we'll just keep the box sizing
the border box
the padding and margin to zero
then what we'll do is we'll go into the
body and give it a width and height of
100
view for width and a height of 100
viewport height
then what we'll do is we need a few
extra divs for the 3d models which you
will be doing last so we will just name
this scene
one
and then we will have
dot scene
two
now
we have these scenes we can just style
them a bit so we can say dot c in one
and we can give its position
of absolute
then we can give it starting from the
left
and a height
of fifty percent of a height of hundred
percent
and a width of fifty percent
the same thing we can do for
scene two
but what we will do is keep the position
to absolute but we will start from the
right side
then we can give it a height of 100 and
a width
of 50
percent
all right now we're done with the html
and css and we can move forward to
javascript so how do we import the 3js
library well like i said we could do it
in multiple ways but for this
workshop we will be importing it through
our cdn so the first thing you want to
do is go on your browser and go to
3js.org
and you will land on this page
then what you can do is go to the
documentation installation and scroll
down to the cdn now what you want to do
is copy till at the rate and then paste
that in
the file now for for the version you
want to keep it to
0.129.0
now
this won't work immediately what you
need to do is go into your index.html
file and where you added the javascript
you have to give it a type
equal to
[Music]
module
now you'll be able to import things
through the cdn properly now what's the
first thing that we can do is we can
make a box
now
the box is going to be the basic version
of 3.js this will help us set all the
basic stuff right and
help us understand how we can
animate this later on so we need to
first set up a scene
so what we do is we have a constant and
we name that c
and we set that equal to 3
dot
c
now to check if this is working what we
can do is type
console
log
and c
then what we can do is just run it
and go into the console
and as you can see we have loaded the
scene
now what we can do is we can import a
few extra other things such as the
camera so we have constant camera is
equal to new 3 dot
perspective
perspective camera
and now we're going to have to set this
to a few things first we have to set the
fov which is
what what we're going to use is 35 foe
then we're going to have to set the
width and we're going to have to set the
aspect ratio and we do that by saying
the window
dot inner
height
inner width
divided by
the window
dot inner
height
and finally we have to set the near and
far clipping
for this workshop we'll be doing 0.1 as
in ear clipping and 1000 as the far
clipping the near and far clipping just
shows us where we need to place our
objects before they are clipped out of
the scene
now what we can do is set up our light
gets new
three dot
right
this will be directional
right
and now what we need to set is the color
of our light so we want a white light so
we'll keep it as
all f
and we also want to select our intensity
so the intensity for this will be 0.5 we
don't want it to be too bright
then what we can do is we can set up a
renderer this is what will take all our
cam our scene our camera lights and the
object and put them all together so what
we can say is constant
renderer
is equal to new
3
dot
web
gl renderer
now what we need to do is
we need to have our item so our item
like i said is going to be a box
so we do a setup as box
gets
new three dot
box
geometry
and then what we need to set is the x y
and z axis for this so because we want
the cube we will have to have them all
same so we can set it as one comma one
comma
one
all right now we need to give a material
for our
box
so what we can say is const material
gets new
3 dot
mesh
basic material
and what we can do in here is set the
color so we can say color is
0 x
2 2 2 2 f
and then what we need to do is combine
all of this using a mesh so what we do
is new 3 dot
mesh
and then we need to feed it our box and
the material that we're going to be
using for it so we say box and material
now
if you save this and run it
you're going to see that nothing shows
up
and that's because we haven't put it in
the renderer yet
what we need to do is first set up our
camera position light the renderer and
the document
so we do that by saying the cam
camera dot position
set
and
what we can do is either put it like
this
which gives us the x y and z
or what we can do is say camera dot
for position
dot c
is equal to five
then what we need to do is set our light
we have our light and we say dot
position
dot set
zero comma zero comma
one
now you can do the same thing for the
camera but uh it's best to just leave it
like this because
we won't need to set our x and y for the
light
now we need to put our renderer size so
what we say is render
dot set
size
set to the
windows inner width and enter
windows inner height
so we can just copy that here
comma
and paste that
now what we need to do is set the
renderer color this is the backdraw of
our backdrop of our renderer so if we
leave it blank it will be a black state
so what we can do is just not set it for
now
then what we do is select the document
dot body
dot append
child
and then we can say render
dot
dom element
this will put our renderer on the
browser
then what we can do is add all of this
to the scene so scene
dot add
and then we can add our mesh which
includes the box and the material
and then we also want to add our
light
all right
now what we can do is
we can add an animation function which
allows us to rotate the box
but first let's see if we can see our
box
well as you can see it's still not
showing up and the reason for that is we
still haven't added that to our render
what we can do is say render
dot
render
we give it our scene
and feed it our camera
as you can see we now have a square on
our screen the thing is it's a box and
the position of our camera doesn't allow
us to see what is behind it so what we
can do is we can add an animation that
allows us to
rotate the
box
so we can say it's function animate
we're going to put the renderer inside
and then what we can say is request
animation frame
and animate
then we can say it's mesh
dot rotation
dot y
plus equal to
0.01 and the reason we're putting it so
slow is because it is in seconds so what
we can say is animate
and then we can run it
as you can see now we have a cube that
is rotating
as you can see we have
a little bit of jittering on the
edges and the way we can take uh
the way we can fix that is by calling
our renderer
so we say render dot
set
clear
or set
pixel
ratio
and then we say device
pixel ratio
and when we save that you can see that
we have a much more smoother animation
all right now that we're done with
adding the cube what we can do is have a
little more fun with this now we can add
a plane and we can edit this plane to
make it our home landing page so how do
we do that well we're gonna have to
change a few things first we're gonna
need to change our box into a panel
or a pane
and then what we can say is
new3js
dot
plane
geometry
now this will take in four values so the
first value will be the width
the height and then we're gonna have the
width segmentation and the height
segmentation this will come into play
uh in the future uh
when we have to add a little bit more
depth to our plane now we're also going
to have to change our material so what
we need to do is we're going to say
we're going to remove our color
and then what we can say is
side
is equal to
3
dot
double side
then what we have is
our
flat shading
and what we can do is
it's shading with a capital s just
remember to have the capital s
and then set that to
3
dot
flat
shading
and finally we need to have
vertex colors vertex
colors
and we set that to true
and then we can save that
now what we need to do is set our mesh
or our material
yes no we need to set our
mesh to change with our plane
and have the same material because we've
already edited that
now what we can do is we can keep the
camera position same we can add a little
bit of light more extra light and
we can run this and see what happens
as you can see it hasn't run yet and we
can check why that is
and it says flat shading is not a
property of this so let's check what is
so what we need to do is for the
material we need to change it from a
mesh basic material into a mesh
material
and this should work
now if you run this we should see that
we have a pane that has disappeared into
the background so what we can do is
change the background color
by saying
render dot
set clear
color
and then we can set this to white by
saying zero f
f f f and we can set the intensity to
one
now you can see that our plane shows up
all right
and now what we can do is we can move on
to the next part which is
adding a little more depth to our plane
all right now that we're done with the
regular plane what we can do is we can
add a little more extra features to this
to make it look
more 3d and more realistic so what we
can do is we can first increase the size
of our plane to 3
and for it to have five
segments of the width five segments of
the height
now we can also add a little bit of
backlighting by saying the const of
backlight
is equal to new
three directional light and we set it
the same value as the one
above
the only thing that will change from
this light is its position so what we
can say is here
back
light
dot position
dot set
zero comma zero comma
minus two
this will position the light behind the
object
now what we need to do is save all this
all our mesh
objects into an array and then we can do
that by saying
const array
gets new
or gets mesh
dot
geometry
dot
attributes
dot position
this is the position of the mesh of each
vertices in in the mesh
into this array
then what we need to do is we need to
take these
vertices and
change the z level of it to give it a
different one for each of the vertices
so we can do that by having a for loop
and in this for loop
we
[Music]
let
i equal to
zero
and then i less than array dot length
and then we say i plus equal to three
this will loop through all the three
every three indexes in the array and we
do this because we only want to access
the z index not the x or y
so what we can do now is
const of z is equal to array
1 i
plus 2
and then we say array
i plus 2
is equal to z
plus math
dot random
now if you run this we can be able to
see that our mesh
has
or looks kind of funny because it has a
different
z index for each vertice in that
in itself
now what we need to do is we can
increase the size
to 10
and add a few extra vertices
or segments
now that we have set the plane we can
just run and check our
plane and as you can see we have
different depths of the vertices
to have a better view we can just reduce
the size of the width and height
save that and check it out
yeah
now it's showing
now what we can do is we can add a few
extra features what i will be doing is i
will show you how to add a hover over
feature
that
changes the color or on hover
so let's get started with that
so first we need to first initialize our
mouse
by saying const
mouse
and then in that we set the
x
to undefined
and y
to undefined
now that we have our
mouse we can set our raycaster
you say const
raycaster
gets new
3 dot
raycaster with a capital r
all right now what we need to do is we
need to set the initial colors
along with a few extra other
settings now we need to do is have a
const array
for color we do that by saying
we have the brackets
then we have for loop
let
i equal to 0
i less than
the mesh
the geometry dot
attributes dot position
dot count
and then i plus plus
then we need to say color
dot push
and then pushing out a
black color which is the color of our
background
then we need to set our
attributes the geometry attributes to
meshed our geometry dot attributes
and then we say
color
and then we say new 3
dot
buffer
attribute
we give this new float
32 array
and inside that we assign our colors
all right now that is done we need to
add to our animation function we need to
add a couple of things we need to add
our normal initial color which is black
and then we also need to add our hover
color
this will be the white color but before
that we need to import the gsap module
this will help us with the with the
with the hover effect so
what we can do is
insert the cdn for the gsap which i've
already copied here and will be
available in the description you can
just copy and paste that
and then what you can do is go into
the
app.js
and then inside the animation function
we can start working on the hover effect
you can say that the array
the raycaster dot set
from
camera
we give it the mouse comma
camera
then
we need to set our intersection so we
say const enter
section
is equal to the ray caster
dot
enter
sect object
now what we can do is
set our normal and hover colors
so
we do that by
giving const of normal
a few rgb the rgb values so we have r of
zero comma
b of zero
we get zero
and g gets zero
and this is because our
background color is black
and then we can just copy this
paste it and then give it our hover
color
since i have a color it's going to be
white we can just set all of these
values to one
now
we can access our g sub module and say
g sub dot 2.
and then we give it hover
and then we say rg
r
g and v
we say normal
assign it to normal.r
and then
normal.g
and normal
dot b
all right
then we need to set our duration
duration to one
to one second
and then on update
we need to update the colors so we can
say
function is equal to
color
dot set
x
enter
section of zero
dot face
of a
gets hover
of r
now we're gonna have to repeat this a
couple of times
nine times in total
so we can copy this
paste it paste it
we have to change a few things so the x
will go to y
and then x to z
and our x value will be r
our y value will be
g
and our z value will be
now we have to copy this
and paste it
twice and then we can change the face to
b
and then finally the last one we can
change it to c
all right now we need to push these
colors by saying color
dot
needs update
equal to true
all right we can run
the file
and as you can see we our pane has
loaded up and our hover effect is
working and now what we can do is we can
close this part and we can move on to
the 3d models
as you can see i already have a few
uh two uh files with
gltf 3d models and we also have a 3js
master zip file
now what we can do is we can make
another
javascript file we can name it new app
dot js
and we can go into our html and we can
link
that file here
what we need to do is also
comment out
the
two other script files
and now we can work on
on the new app.js
what we can do from the old one is we
can copy the import
and paste it
now
the importance of this file
is what i will explain right now
we will open this in explorer
and then we will open up the file in zip
now
what we need to do is from this zip file
we need to get the path of where we can
get the gltf loader and
we need to do this because we need to
import it as
a module
so
the gltf is located in examples
jsm loaders
and the gltf loader so what we need to
do is
copy this
and we need to import
the gltf
so we'll say gltf
loader
and then
we can
add our paths so it's examples slash jsm
slash loaders
slash
gltf loader
and don't forget to add the dot js
now that we've imported our gltf loader
we can now
import our 3d models into javascript and
display them on the browser so to do
that we can have a couple of things
since we have two files that we are
going to display or two models that we
are going to display we can have two of
each
um
variables we can say let
container
contain one
can name the second one container two
then we need to have two cameras so we
can say
let cam one
let cam two
that cam
let's render
one
let's render
two
then we have different scenes so we have
say let's see in
one
let's
scene 2
then we have
to import our models so we have let
house and then we have let shoe
now what we do is we can make a function
so we can say function
house
show
and for now whatever we've learned from
our
previous app.js
what we need to do is we can use those
same
um
settings that we have before so we can
say container
one is equal to document
that query selector
so query selector
and now we already had a few scenes
prepared so what we can do is we can
select this as dot scene one
and then we can say scene
one dot
or scene one gets new
three
dot
see
all right
then what we can do is we can set our
um
fov
our near clipping far clipping and
aspect ratio
so what we need to do is set cam
1
equal to nu
3 dot
for
perspective
camera
and then we can set our fov to 25 comma
container so we can say it's container
one
dot
client
with
and then
divided by container one dot
client
height
then our new clipping which is 0.1 and
1000 which is our far clipping
save that and we can continue
now we need to set our camera position
so we can say cam one dot
position
dot set
0 comma 3
comma 30
and then we can set our ambient light
so const
ambient equals new 3 dot
ambient light
and then we can give that a hex value of
40
40 and 40
along with the intensity
then you can have a light
new
three dot
directional
right
and we can put this to white
and we can set our intensity to 2.
now we can set our light position
to
[Music]
position
dot set
and then
send it at 50 comma 50 comma 100
finally we have to add our scene
elements
dot and we can add ambient
along with the
light now that we've done that as you
know we have to now add our renderer so
our renderer will be render
one
gets new three
dot web
gl
renderer
and now we can also set
a few aspects of our
uh webgl renderer
such as the anti
aliasing
alias
is set to true
along with
alpha
equal to true this will just ensure that
the rendering is smooth
then we can set our
size
and then we can keep it
the same as our aspect ratio
width
and then we can name this
height
finally we can set our pixel ratios to
ensure that there is no
jittering on the edges of the mod
uh models
so render one dot set
pixel ratio
set to
device
pixel
ratio
all right
the last thing that we need to do is
import our model so all we have to do is
say let loader is equal to new gltf
loader
and then we give
loader
dot load and then now we have to give
the path so dot slash
house because it's in the root folder
and then we need to select the scene
from there
dot gltf
then we need to mention that our
function that we're going to use is
gltf
and then scene
1
dot add
the gltf gltf.c
now what we can say is house we get the
gltf
dot scene
dot children
and we select the first one
which is in first index
and then we can call our animate
function which we need which we will set
up
in a second
now what we can do is
we can save all of this
and copy this function
and paste it again
and then we can change this to shoes
shoe
and we need to select scene two
just make sure we have to rename all our
variables
otherwise they will overlap with each
other and we do not want that to happen
so except
everything from its original to 2
so we have renderer 2
vendor 2
and renderer 2.
now we need to change this house into
shoe
and we also need to change our
path
change our
container and that should be it
now what we need to do is we need to
have a function that loads this
so we can have
a function called
and
animate
one
and then we say request
animation frame
of
animate one
now we take our render our
renderer
dot so render one dot render
and then we give scene
1 and cam
1.
what we can also do is we can add
rotation so we can say house dot
rotation
dot z
we can do plus equal to
0.005
perfect now we can copy this
and paste it again
just need to ensure that we change this
to animate two
and change house to shoe
and the render from
one to two and same with the scene and
the camera
all right after adding the animation
functions we need to now call them in
the main functions so in the first
function we can say animate
1
and then
the second function we can call animate
2.
now we also need to add these to the
containers
uh we need to add the containers to the
dom element so if you remember it would
be container
one dot
append
child
and then we say render
one dot dom
element
save that we can copy it
and we can paste that
the second function
just remember to rename
them
and then finally what we can do is now
call the main functions which is house
show
and
shoe show
save it and we should now run it and as
you can see
our animation our 3d models are loaded
now you can see that our shoe is
slightly lower and that's an easy fix so
all you can
do is
change the the camera position so
instead of three you can make it one
or
you can make it six
as you can see
the direction of our shoe changes
and that will conclude our workshop
thank you so that's it for today's
workshop today we managed to cover a few
things with 3gs such as the scene camera
light lighting objects and material we
also managed to render all of this on
the browser while using gsap for hover
animations we also managed to
import a 3d model into the browser
if you enjoyed consider hitting the like
and subscribe button and to stay up to
date with our content you can follow us
on our social media thank you
you